مرحبا بكم من جديد اصدرت السلطه الصينيه
اشعارا بشان تخفيف تدبير مكافحه وباء
كرونه وبموجب الاشعار خفضت اسرته نطاقه
وتكرار الكشف عن الفيروس كما اعفت سكان
العديد من الاماكن من الشهادات السلبيه
للاختبار وتطبيقات الرموز الصحيح
وشددت على تسريع التطعيم المسنين ضد
الفيروس كما سمعت للمدارس الخاليه من
الاصابات ان تبدا بانشطه التدريس العاديه
ووقف التعليم عن بعد
معنى مين بيجيب مدير مكتب الجزيره الناصر
عبد الحق ناصر مرحبا بك معنا اذا حدثنا عن
اثر هذا التخفيف للاجراءات ونعلم ان بهذه
الاجراءات كان رفض كبير ومظاهرات خرجت
بفعل هذا التضييق الذي كان
نعم محمد لا شك ان مثل هذه القرارات لا قد
رضا لدى المواطنين الصينيين وبالذات ان
هذه القرارات استهدفت تلك القيود التي
طالما اثارت سخط وغضب المواطنين الصينيين
خلال الفتره الماضيه وقامت كما ذكرت على
اثرها احتجاجات في عده مدن صينيه ومن بين
تلك الاجراءات المستهدفه هي همم
تخفيف او عدم الطلب من المواطنين اجراء
فحص الكشف عن فيروس كورونا الذي كان همم
المواطنين مطالبون به يوميا ويصطفون في
طوابير طويله همم في همم اجواء بارده همم
في هذا الوقت من فصل الشتاء بالاضافه الى
ايضا قرارات تتعلق بعمليه الحجر الصحي
لاولئك الذين بتظهر عليهم اعراض الاصابه
بالفايروس فبدل همم من ان يخضعوا لعمليه
الحجر في مناطق واماكن عامه تخصصها
الحكومه همم الان سوف يقومون بعمليه همم
الحجر هذه داخل منازلهم بالاضافه الى ذلك
همم ايضا وقف الطلب من المواطنين اظهار
شهاده خلوهم من همم همم المرض عند دخولهم
الى الاماكن العامه والمراكز الحكوميه
ومراكز التسوق باستثناء بعض الاماكن مثل
المستشفيات ودور رعايه المسنين ودور رعايه
الاطفال فان هذه الاماكن ما زالت تطلب من
يدخلونها شهادات همم اثبات يعني
فحصهم وخلوهم من الفيروس خلال فتره
40 ساعه ايضا شددت القرارات على همم تطعيم
كبار السن حيث نعلم بان السلطات عندما
اتخذت هذه القرارات الجديده هي تخشى من
انتشار الفيروس من جديد خاصه وان تاثيراته
ستكون اقوى على المسنين وكبار السن واا
بينما همم في الصين يعيش اكثر من 200
مليون مسن تتجاوز اعمارهم 60 عاما بالتالي
السلطات تخشى من انتشار الفيروس والاصابات
بينهم خاصه وان همم البلاد هنا في الصين
تفتقر الى البنيه التحتيه القويه همم
الطبيه يعني استقبال اعداد كبيره من
المصابين في حال حدوث همم يعني اي طارئ
ايضا هناك قرار جديد بوقف
الطلب همم الفحص او همم يعني اظهار همم
الرمز الصحي لكل من يدخل المطارات همم
الدوليه في بيجين بعد ان كانوا بعد ان كان
الجميع يطالبون بذار مثل هذه الاثباتات
لكن ما زال المسافرون والقادمون من خارج
الصين مطالبون
باظهار هذه همم الشهادات والرموز الصحيه
همم في النهايه الان ما زال الجميع ينتظر
بان يكون هناك اجراءات المزيد من
الاجراءات تتعلق بالقادمين من الخارج محمد
لانه هناك الكثير من الاجانب ممن ينتظرون
العوده الى الصين لممارسه اعمالهم
التجاريه وهناك ايضا العديد من الشركات
التجاريه الصينيه تنتظر بان يكون هناك
اجراءات جديده همم يعني همم تقدم تسهيلات
للقادمين همم الى
منها
في بيجين ناصر عبد الحق شكرا جزيلا لك